Film Courage: How many talented ones, truly
great writers would you say have MFA’s,
even have a bachelor’s versus those that
maybe don’t?
Do you think it’s really necessary?
David Willis: Gosh…I don’t know?
I know someone who just got a Master’s in
television writing from Loyola [University].
But I really don’t know everyone’s resumes
in these groups and what they’re into.
The nice thing about (I’ve noticed) people
who go to college and they get these screenwriting
degrees is when you’re young, you just don’t
have that much to write about, yet?
Because you haven’t…it’s like a lot
of comedians don’t get successful until
they are at least like 30 because they just
haven’t done that much yet.
You just need time on the planet and as a
writer the more time you have on the planet,
the more you have to draw from.
So that’s the great thing about going to
college is that while you’re young and still
learning you can learn the craft and the technique
so that when you do have more things to write
about, you have the technique.
Film Courage: You’ve got to get bitter first!
Probably around 35 is the time for this to
happen.
David Willis: Well writers are frequently
(even when they’re successful) there’s
a bitterness.
When writers get together they just love to
complain.
If you don’t have an agent, you love to
complain about that you don’t have an agent.
When you do have an agent you complain that
they are not sending out your stuff enough.
Okay, when you sell a pilot you complain because
the pilot didn’t get made.
When you get the pilot made, you complain
because it didn’t go to series.
When you have a series you complain that it
only ran two years instead of six years.
Okay and I guess if you are Chuck Lorre you
complain that you only have three series on
the air instead of six.
I mean writers will always find a reason to
complain.
We’re creative that way.
Film Courage: Right, but they voice what most
people are already thinking, but maybe they
just don’t want to say it.
So those that are embittered enough to say
it, we’re like “Yes!
We won’t say that but we want to
hear it.”
David Willis: Well, that’s a writer’s
job to voice things that people can’t say.